hi I'm Andrea Crawford with IBM cloud
and we're going to talk cloud migration
take a look at this picture here we have
enterprise infrastructure this is
typically where a lot of our compute
workloads are bare-metal enterprise core
systems mainframe on-premise data center
we have private cloud over here also on
premise but cloud capabilities and full
effect and then we have public cloud
this is off premise cloud capabilities
now many of our enterprises are still
struggling to get workloads off of the
enterprise infrastructure and on to the
cloud so when we migrate enterprise
workloads to private our public we call
that migration and this is all about
understanding enterprise workloads and
their characteristics in terms of
whether they should land on premise
cloud or off premise public cloud we
also have modernize there could be some
workloads over here that we might be
able to refactor if you will think about
a mainframe monolithic code if we could
put some api's on top of that to expose
core business function we might be able
to modernize functions in a way where
those api's might be able to live here
and then we have our third use case
build native
for those workloads that live over here
if we have an opportunity to do things
over in a way where we could design
cloud native apps to live either here or
here we would be able to infuse
qualities like correlation IDs to track
micro services and where traffic flows
we would be able to leverage a lot of
the core functions for load balancing
service management here in the clouds
the clouds offer us some core
capabilities within the platform so that
we can free up some of the logistics and
the application layer so that we can be
more innovative which brings me to the
benefits so moving
migrating modernizing applications to
the cloud is cost-effective so we can
lower our costs specifically around
public around up X and being able to let
our cloud providers take care of a lot
of the management of those workloads
another benefit scalability because
cloud heavily leverages virtualization
and the ability to do things like Cloud
Foundry kubernetes we can leverage the
core services in those particular models
but we also have the flexibility to well
to bare metal and even virtual machines
another benefit security what are the
great things about cloud is we don't
have to worry about a lot of the core
services that we would have had to worry
about over here a lot of our cloud
providers nowadays actually address a
lot of the security concerns where you
have compliance regulation data concerns
these are services that can be provided
here we also have as our
last benefit accelerated adoption so by
leveraging these services in the cloud
like service routing service discovery
load balancing we don't have to worry
about that at the application level so
we really start to understand why
enterprises are really chomping at the
bit to move workloads from here to here
or here and that is cloud migration
thanks for watching this video
be sure to LIKE and subscribe if you
have any questions or comments drop a
line below